>> Jesse: SHOCKING NEW VIDEO
TENTATIVE A JOURNALIST BEING
ATTACKED ON THE JOB.
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO SHOWING THE
MAN BEING ACCOSTED AND ACCOSTED
AND FORCIBLY REMOVED FROM A
PUBLIC SPEAKING EVENT FOR NONE
OTHER THAN AMERICAN URBAN RADIO
NETWORK AND CNN'S APRIL RYAN,
WHO IRONICALLY IS KNOWN TO BE A
CHAMPION FOR PRESS FREEDOM.
WATCH THIS.
>> HELLO.
TO ALL OF YOU, WHEN I --
>> DON'T TOUCH MY CAMERA, PLEAS
PLEASE.
DON'T YOU DARE, PUT THAT DOWN.
IF THAT'S MY.
>> HOW DARE YOU COME IN HERE.
[INDISTINCT SHOUTING]
>> Jesse: JOINING ME NOW
EXCLUSIVELY IS THE MAN IN THAT
VIDEO, THE EDITOR OF NEW
BRUNSWICK TODAY.
ALL RIGHT, CHARLIE, YOU WENT
INTO THIS EVENT WERE APRIL RYAN
WAS GOING TO BE SPEAKING, WANTED
TO COVER IT FROM A STRAIGHT NEWS
PUT PERSPECTIVE.
YOU GOT CREDENTIALED.
NO ONE EVER TOLD YOU, OR IT WAS
NEVER WRITTEN THAT THERE WAS NO
FILMING, AND THEN WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I WAS THERE WITH MY CAMERA ON
A TRIPOD, RIGHT NEXT TO ANOTHER
CAMERA ON A TRIPOD.
I ENJOYED THE EVENING FOR A
COUPLE HOURS, THEN THIS FELLOW
CAME UP TO ME AND STARTED, YOU
KNOW, ASK ME WHO I WAS, WHY IS
YOUR CAMERA HERE, AND I GAVE HIM
MY BUSINESS CARD, EXPLAINED, AND
HE TOLD ME IF I DON'T TAKE THAT
CAMERA DOWN, HE WILL TAKE THE
CAMERA DOWN FOR ME.
ONE THING LED TO ANOTHER, HE
GRABBED THE CAMERA AND
HIGHTAILED IT OUT OF THE ROOM.
>> Jesse: REALLY YOU THE ONLY
ONE BOOTED OUT OF, OTHERS LEFT A
FILM?
>> I WAS THE ONLY ONE, AND I
WASN'T BOOTED, I VOLUNTARILY
LEFT BECAUSE HE STOLE MY CAMERA.
>> Jesse: OTHER PEOPLE WERE
ABLE TO FILM AND YOU WEREN'T?
>> THERE WERE OTHER PEOPLE WITH
VIDEO AND TAKING PICTURES.
>> Jesse: MAY BE THEY MISTOOK
YOU FOR ME.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
MISUNDERSTANDING WAS, BUT I WAS
DEFINITELY FELT VIOLATED.
>> Jesse: SO IT WAS A
BODYGUARD, YOU BELIEVE, OF APRIL
RYAN.
>> YES, THAT IS WHAT THE POLICE
WERE TOLD.
MISS RYAN'S SECURITY GUARD, JOE
MORRIS.
>> Jesse: AND HE PUT HIS HANDS
ON YOU?
>> YES.
>> Jesse: WHAT DID HE DO
SPECIFICALLY PHYSICALLY TO YOU?
>> I WAS ABLE TO RETRIEVE THE
CAMERA, AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE
VIDEO, AND THEN HE WON'T GIVE ME
ANY SPACE, STAYS RIGHT NEAR ME.
I'M TRYING TO USE THE CAMERA TO
GET AN IMAGE OF HIM, TO MAKE
SURE I GET -- DOCUMENT WHO HE
IS, AND HE DOESN'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN, SO HE IS STICKING HIS
HAND IN THE FACE OF THE CAMERA,
HITTING THE MICROPHONE, AND I
KIND OF SNUCK AWAY TO GET SOME
SPACE FROM HIM, AND HE CHASED ME
DOWN, GRABBED MY ARM, TWISTED MY
ARM BEHIND MY BACK.
>> Jesse: WOW.
AND YOU ARE NOT AN IDEOLOGICAL
OPPONENT OF MISS RYAN.
>> WHEN I LEFT THE HOUSE THAT
DAY, I WAS A FAN OF HERS.
I WAS LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
HER REMARKS, MAY BE LEARNING A
THING OR TWO SINCE SHE HAS BEEN
A JOURNALIST LONGER THAN I HAVE.
>> Jesse: SO THE PRESS
ATTACKED FREEDOM OF THE PRESS,
IN YOUR OPINION?
>> THIS WAS AN ATTACK ON OUR
FREEDOMS, YES, ABSOLUTELY.
THIS CANNOT STAND.
>> Jesse: WE REACHED OUT TO
HEAR FROM APRIL RYAN.
SHE HAS NOT EXERCISED HER
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS, AND
NEITHER HAS CNN.
NEITHER HAS AMERICAN URBAN RADIO
NETWORKS.
UNFORTUNATELY, SHE IS JUST GOING
TO TRY TO RIDE THIS OUT, I
GUESS, AND PRETEND IT HAS NOT
HAPPENED, EVEN THOUGH IT IS ALL
OVER THE INTERNET.
I THINK WE HAVE A TWEET FROM HER
FROM A LITTLE WHILE BACK, CAN WE
PUT THIS TWEET UP?
IT SAYS "I HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS IN THIS
COUNTRY BY A PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION -- SPEAKING OF
TRUMP.
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS, WE ARE NOT
IN RUSSIA OR CHINA.
OUR JOBS ARE TO ASK QUESTIONS.
A LOT OF TIMES QUESTIONS THEY
DON'T LIKE.
WHAT IN THE WORLD."
THAT'S FROM LAST JULY.
AND SHE'S ACCUSING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OF BEING LIKE
CHINA AND RUSSIA.
AND THEN, IN AUGUST 2019, SHE
HERSELF, AND HER SQUAD, ACTS
LIKE CHINA AND RUSSIA.
THINK THAT IS HYPOCRITICAL?
>> I THINK THIS IS SUPREMELY
IRONIC AND UNEXPECTED, AND
CERTAINLY NOT BEHAVIOR THAT IS
BEFITTING SOMEBODY WHO KNOWS
JOURNALISM.
TO SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN IN THE
FIELD FOR A LONG TIME.
SHE WOULDN'T WANT TO BE TREATED
LIKE THAT, SO I DON'T SEE WHY
SHE CAN COME IN TO MY COMMUNITY,
AND HAVE HER PEOPLE COME AND
VIOLATE OUR LAWS LIKE THAT.
AN ATTACK FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.